the cost of the pandemic has been huge
with the biggest fall in output for 300
years the necessitated government
expenditure of 400 billion pounds and
the aftershocks are still being felt
across the world with a global spike in
energy prices the impact we're seeing on
the cost of food and it's precisely
because this government got the big
calls right and made the tough decisions
during the pandemic that we had the
fastest economic growth in the g7 last
year and we'll return to that status by
the way by 2024 mr speaker and therefore
have therefore have the fiscal firepower
to help families up and down the country
with all the pressures they face now and
we will continue to use all our
ingenuity and compassion
for as long as it takes
and my right home will offend the
chancellor and i will be saying more
about this in the days to come
but at the same time as we help people
we need the legislative firepower to fix
the underlying problems in energy supply
in housing in infrastructure and in
skills which are driving up costs for
families across the country and this
queen's speech takes those issues
head-on
and above all we're tackling the
economic challenges with the best
solution of all and that's an
ever-growing number of high-wage
high-skill jobs mr speaker jobs jobs
jobs during the pandemic this government
worked night and day at extraordinary
speed to protect lives and livelihoods
across our whole united kingdom whether
by injecting 400 billion pounds of
direct support for the economy and
supporting jobs through our world
leaning furlough scheme becoming the
first country in the world to administer
an approved covid vaccine
or by delivering the largest testing
program and the fastest vaccine booster
campaign
in europe
all of which allowed us to retre retain
one of the most open economies and
societies across the continent which we
wouldn't have done by the way for this
device body office with the fastest
growth in the g7 last year now we will
bring that same urgency impatience and
determination to deliver on our mission
of getting our country back on track and
easing the burdens on families and
visitors across the land that's why
we've already committed 9.1 billion
pounds to assist with energy costs alone
we're giving back 150 pounds to people
in their council tax
cutting fuel duty
increasing the warm homes discount
creating no
let me call it increasing the warms
homes discount creating a tax cut for 30
million workers by raising the national
insurance threshold delivering the
biggest ever increase in the national
living wage worth an extra thousand
pounds a year for those working full
time uh mr speaker but however great our
compassion and ingenuity we cannot
simply spend our way out of this problem
we need to grow out of this problem by
creating hundreds of thousands
[Applause]
of new high-wage high-skill jobs across
the country